>> Tucker: CALIFORNIA AND NEW
JERSEY SPENT DECADES OF BEACONS
OF OPPORTUNITY TO THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
NOW PEOPLE CAN'T FLEE THEM FAST
ENOUGH.
IN CALIFORNIA HOUSES ARE
UNAFFORDABLE.
AND THE MIDDLE-CLASS IS GONE
WITH THE IMMIGRANTS.
AND DEMOCRATIC SENATORS HARRIS
AND COREY BOOKER HAVE
A SOLUTION.
SMOKE MORE WEED.
>> I AM SIGNING ON TO THE
MARIJUANA JUSTICE ACT.
>> IT TWO OF THE LAST THREE
PRESIDENTS ADSPLITTED TO USING
DRUGS.
CONGRESS AND SENATORS USE
MARIJUANA.
>> OTHER COMMUNITIES IT IS
CRIMINALIZED.
>> IT IS TIME TO LEGALIZE
MARIJUANA IN OUR STATE AND
EXPUNGE THE RECORDS OF THOSE
CARRYING THE CONVICTIONS.
N
>> ALL BECAUSE OF A DRUG THAT
SHOULD BE LEGAL.
>> Tucker: GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I WANT TO PREFACE OUR
CONVERSATION I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE WHO SMOKE WEED SHOULD BE
IN JAIL.
THE DRUG WAR DID NOT WORK WITH.
AND ALCOHOL IS IN A LOT OF WAYS
WORSE THAN MARIJUANA, AND SO I
BELIEVE ALL THAT.
I AM JUST AMAZED THAT THE RULING
CLASS FAILING TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR OWN PEOPLE IS TESTIFYING
THEM TO SMOKE MORE WEED AND BE
MORE PASSIVE AND LESS CONCERNED
BY OUR FAILURES.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS AN
ACCIDENT, DO YOU?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
TELLING US TO SMOKE MORE WEED.
PEOPLE ARE SMOKING BEAD AND 80
YEAR WAS REEFER MADNESS IS NOT
STOPPING.
AND THERE ARE NUMEROUS POTENTIAL
MEDICAL BENEFITS OF MARIJUANA
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T STUDIED.
WE NEED TO GET RID OF THAT
CLASSIFICATION.
AND STATES LIKE COLORADO
GENERATED A QUARTER OF BILLION
A YEAR.
>> Tucker: NOW YOU ARE MAKING MY
CASE FOR ME.
I THINK WE SHOULD FULLY EXPLORE
THE POTENTIAL HEALTH EFFECTS OF
CANNABIS.
THERE ARE PROBABLY BIG ONES.
I AM ALL FOR THAT.
BUT WHY SHOULDN'T I BE
SUSPICIOUS OVER HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS ARE SLEEPING
OUTSIDE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE HARRIS HAVE
DONE A TERRIBLE JOB TO TAKING
CARE OF THE PEOPLE AND HER
SOLUTION IS SMOKE MORE WEED SO I
CAN HAVE MORE MONEY IN THE TAX
COFFERS AND YOU WILL BE LESS
LIKELY STAGE A REVOLUTION
AGAINST MY LEADERSHIP.
I AM NOT PARINOID.
>> SHE IS A NEW SENATOR, AND SO.
>> SHE WAS ELECTED STATEWIDE FOR
A LONG TIME.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION.
THERE IS A LOT OF CARE NEEDED
THERE AND IF THAT REVENUE GOES
TO PSYCHOLOGICAL AND ADDICTION
CARE THAT IS A WONDERFUL THING.
AND SO IF THE PEOPLE ARE ALREADY
SMOKING MARIJUANA AND CONSUMING
OR EDIBLES OR OILS, LET'S
LEGALIZE TAX AND GET IT OFF OF
THE SHELVES.
AND WHO IS BRINGING IT ACROSS
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
YOU WANT TO STOP THEM?
>> CARTELS ARE JUST A MARKET AND
WHEN THE PRICE OF ANYTHING GOES
UP.
IF YOU CAN UNDERCUT IT
ILLEGALLY.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT WITH
CIGARETTES AND THEY ARE
BOOTLEGGED.
IT IS NOT AS SIMPLE AS YOU ARE
MAKING IT.
DON'T COMPARE MARIJUANA TO
ALCOHOL.
I DON'T DRINK.
COMPARE IT TO SOBRIETY AND BEING
AWARE AND FULLY EXPERIENCING
YOUR LIFE AND FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST MISUSED POWER.
PEOPLE WHO ARE HIGH DON'T DO
THAT.
>> IF THEY ARE DRINKING BEER, IS
THAT ANY DIFFERENT.
IT DIDN'T WORK WITH THE
PROHIBITION.
>> Tucker: WHY SHOULDN'T I BE
SUSPICIOUS.
THEY HAVE FAILED THEIR OWN
PEOPLE AND THEN ENCOURAGING US
TO SMOKE MORE WEED.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ANYBODY IS
ENCOURAGING THEM UNLESS YOU HAVE
CANCER AND YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
KEEP YOUR FOOD DOWN AND THAT IS
A SIDE BENEFITS.
I DON'T SMOKE IT EITHER, TUCKER
AND I SEE THE BENEFITS
MEDICINALLY FOR PEOPLE WHO
BENEFITS AND IF IT IS ONE OF
THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE
ARE DOING IT AND CRIMINAL
ELEMENTS ARE BENEFITTING AND
BRINGING IT OUT IN THE SUNLIGHT.
>> THE GOVERNMENT IS THIS BE
GETTING RICH ON IT.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO BALANCE